(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Deep in the
heart of the Andes Mountains,
one man is growing lots and
lots and lots of potatoes.
Potatoes originated along the southern
border of Peru close to 8,000 years ago.
Julio lives near where
potato growth first thrived,
in one of the most remote
locations in the country.
Julio's family has lived in
the region for generations,
and, thanks to the land's micro-climate,
he's able to grow his unique
potatoes in high quantities.
Julio is always experimenting
with new farming techniques
and relies on other native potato farmers
to create his new strains.
(mellow music)
Potatoes are not only a
staple in Julio's diet,
they are the backbone of Peruvian cuisine,
which is why Julio wants to push
the boundaries of potato farming
and continue his family's legacy.